Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Approximately a 150 episodes ago, we looked
at DeepMind's amazing algorithm that was able
to look at a database with images of birds,
and it could learn about them so much that
we could provide a text description of an
imaginary bird type and it would dream up
new images of them.
It was a truly breathtaking piece of work,
and its main limitation was that it could
only come up with coarse images.
It didn’t give us a lot of details.
Later, we talked about NVIDIA's algorithm
that started out with such a coarse image,
but didn't stop there - it progressively recomputed
this image many times, each time with more
and more details.
This was able to create imaginary celebrities
with tons of detail.
This new work offers a number of valuable
improvements over the previous techniques:
it can train bigger neural networks with even
more parameters, create extremely detailed
images with remarkable performance, so much
so that if you have a reasonably powerful
graphics card, you can run it yourself here.
The link is in the video description.
Training these neural networks is also more
stable than it used to be with previous techniques.
As a result, it not only supports creating
these absolutely beautiful images, but also
gives us the opportunity to exert artistic
control on the outputs.
I think this is super fun, I could play with
this all day long.
What's more, we can also interpolate between
these images, which means that if we have
desirable images A and B, it can compute intermediate
images between them, and the challenging part
is that these intermediate images shouldn't
be some sort of average between the two, which
would be gibberish, but they have to be images
that are meaningful, and can stand on their
own.
Look at this!
Flying colors.
And now comes the best part.
The results were measured in terms of their
inception score.
This inception score defines how recognizable
and diverse these generated images are and
most importantly, both of these are codified
in a mathematical manner to reduce the subjectivity
of the evaluation.
This score is not perfect by any means, but
it typically correlates well with the scores
given by humans.
The best of the earlier works had an inception
score of around 50.
And hold on to your papers, because the score
of this new technique is no less than 166,
and if we would measure real images, they
would score around 233.
What an incredible leap in technology.
And we are even being paid for creating and
playing with such learning algorithms.
What a time to be alive!
A big thumbs up for the authors of the paper
for providing quite a bit of information on
failure cases as well.
We also thank Insilico Medicine for supporting
this video.
They are using these amazing learning algorithms
to create new molecules, identify new protein
targets with the aim to cure diseases and
aging itself.
Make sure to check them out in the video description.
They are our first sponsors, and it's been
such a joy to work with them.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!